peu
le jour anniversaire de la naissance de
la troisième république qui a été choisi
par le gouvernement du général de gaulle
pour date de naissance de la cinquième
c'est place de la république où 100
travailleurs recevait la légion
d'honneur que le général de gaulle à
proposer aux français la nouvelle
constitution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans la légalité que moi même et
mon gouvernement avoir assumé
inspiré le mandat exceptionnel établir
un projet de constitution nouvelle et de
soumettre à la décision du peuple et la
nation qui seul est juge approuvera ou
repoussa notre oeuvre mais c'est en
toute conscience que nous la lui
proposons et le général de gaulle
poursuivait en exposant que les
principes de la nouvelle constitution
détermine il existe au dessus des
querelles politiques
il existe un arbitre national élu par
les citoyens qui ont un mandat public
qui soit chargée d'assurer le
fonctionnement régulier des institutions
il existe un gouvernement qui soit fait
pour gouverner à qui on laisse le temps
et la possibilité qu'il existe un
parlement destiné à représenter la
volonté politique de la nation a voté
les lois à contrôler l'exécutif mais
sans sortir de charlot voix françaises
français de poids s'inspire à quoi
consiste la constitution qui le 28
septembre sera soumise à mon suffrage au
nord de la france
je vous demande de répondre oui
[Applaudissements]
vive la république vive la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]